hey guys I'm Greg oh and I met Lynette
and I are here today to watch from
top-trending ten famous characters based
on real people not 9 I was watching
Passion of the Christ the other day I
was like man this Lord this Jesus
character is like it's totally me
it's like totally me you guys have some
similarities oh dude I can do everything
he does yeah gets a lot of girls when
Betty Boop made her first appearance in
1930
she's so closely resembled popular
American singer Helen Kane that she sued
Fleischer Studios the company
responsible for creating Betty Boop
claiming they exploited her image
everything from Kane's voice look and on
stage personality can be seen
represented in the Betty Boop character
however during trial the studio defended
themselves by arguing that Helen Kane
had actually copied her signature style
from the lesser known singer baby Esther
Jones the former manager of baby Esther
was even brought on to stand where he
claimed that in 1928 Helen Kane had seen
baby Esther perform live and copied her
style baby Esther had passed away before
the lawsuit was solved so the former
manager brought in the only known
recording of baby Esther and played it
for the court the case was quickly
dismissed with Fleischer studio winning
South Park creator Trey Parker named a
character from the show after his
college fiancee LeAnn Adamo the
character in question is Liane Cartman
mother of Eric Cartman who is known
throughout this series to be quite
promiscuous her past is filled with many
illicit acts such as prostitution nude
modeling and sleeping with nearly every
adult character in the show male or
female the reasoning behind Parker's
decision to name is Liane Cartman
after his ex-fiance was because she had
reportedly had
during an engagement ending their
relationship all of which happened years
before the creation of South Park so it
is fair to say Parker held a grudge yeah
the superhero costume designer Edna mode
from the animated movie The Incredibles
is based on the real-life costume
designer Edith Head who was well-known
in the movie industry for her
larger-than-life personality and for the
extreme pride she takes in her work
Edith has been quoted saying I hate
modesty and I am the best of the best
though it does sound like something Edna
mode would have said Milhouse Van Houten
from the TV show The Simpsons known for
being Bart Simpson's gullible best
friend was based on the character Paul
Pfeiffer from The Wonder Years played by
child actor Josh Saviano his big nose
nearsightedness and devious nature were
all borrowed from phifer to help create
Milhouse Murray stole a born in 1903 was
a French professional wrestler better
known by his ring name the French angel
at age 17
tulay was diagnosed with a rare
condition called acromegaly which means
that the bones in his body will suffer
from overgrowth and thickening giving
him a unique odor like look little bit
till they know that nearly 50 years
after this bus animation would use his
likeness to create the lovable ogre
Shrek what did the classic horror
characters Norman Bates
Leatherface and Buffalo Bill have in
common their characters inspiration
real-life killer
Ed Gein also known as the mad butcher
between 1947 and 1950 - Dean would break
into local cemeteries so he could steal
bodies of the recently deceased he would
take the bodies home chop them up and
use the body parts to make different
types of souvenirs and furniture he even
made a whole skin suit out of a woman
and many masks using skin from the faces
later when stealing bodies wasn't good
enough for game he began to take his own
victims and cannibalize them it is
speculated that Edie's obsession with
the dead was started after his
brother died while they were both young
and was further pushed after his abusive
mother forced him to live an isolated
childhood if you are unfamiliar with the
movies Leatherface and his family were
cannibals who regularly made human
furniture and wore human masks Buffalo
Bill and Norman Bates suffered a
traumatic childhood due to their mothers
Bill was abandoned at an abusive foster
home and later grew up to be a serial
killer obsessed with building a human
skin suit while Bates was abused by his
mother for the majority of his life and
became a killer after she passed away
George Lucas the creator of the Star
Wars franchise ordered his creative
department to create a space mobster
using the likeness of actor Sydney
Greenstreet who was always being casted
as the classic fat guys in movies the
team then presented George with the
ghastly space mobster Jabba the Hutt
when JK Rowling's wrote the popular book
series Harry Potter she modeled the
short-tempered potion teacher Severus
Snape after a chemistry teacher she had
in high school
maids John metal ship who also had a
reputation for being quite
short-tempered metal ship was also JK
Rollins mother's boss
so Riley's must have heard a lot about
him when her mother got home from work
during the creation of the character
Aladdin for the 1992 film the Disney
animators looked to use Tom Cruise as
inspiration initially they tried to use
Michael J Fox but found he lacked the
sex appeal they wanted eventually many
of Tom Cruise's mannerisms made it into
the film as well like his mystical
attitude Mike judge the creator of the
TV show beavis and butt-head actually
used the likeness of two of his
university teachers professor David
Kleinfeld for beavis and Jim Branson for
Butthead although the names beavis and
butt-head were actually from two friends
judge had when he was younger
man a lot of fun facts in that one
nicknames his friends were literally
named beavis and butt-head yeah I guess
so a lot of people that they base it off
of they didn't seem like they based them
off of them for good reasons
no it's almost like they picked their
fault yeah I mean the first one is kind
of okay I mean like she was sexy and had
the sex appeal and they caught me there
yeah you know what I think I I don't
know if I necessarily agree with that
one I mean the the anger coming from
that one because I think I even couldn't
Tarantino says in one of his books that
when you in acting when you copy
somebody that's when you don't
necessarily do the best job or you might
not do the best job copying them but you
find something new about yourself yeah
where you find a new character which
Betty Boop did really well and weren't
even planning about becoming your
Kirsten Kendrick I know man that's cool
it's money or something oh right right
okay make sense Betty Boop huh she was
always hot rhymes with the South Park
one I love do revenge yes yeah I've
always thought like any time someone has
really angered me and I want a revenge
I've always wanted to exploit them
wanted to just get watch them on the
internet and just make everyone know
what this person did now [ __ ] up it
was and I feel like this guy did it in
the most ultimate way you know I think I
think that's what South Park is all
about bringing up modern you know topics
like issues is making it worse
and I can't just leave with everybody on
the show yeah parent like she's like
pretty promiscuous
my kind of woman just what I need right
now oh I think out of all the ones where
I'm like that looks pretty similar Edith
Head I was like woah they look exactly
the same you know and I'm surprised I've
never noticed that before
I think Edna mode is one of my favorite
characters in a Disney movie ever
yeah I mean I've won her tit as I like
my seats and stuff oh dammit
you know because I can't make certain
jokes
they just keep popping in my head it's
hard it's hard being you know it's hard
breathe I felt so bad for the Millhouse
guy because they're like we're gonna
take his turkey look at big nose it's
just like kind of making fun of the
actual guy and then but you know what
Milhouse is one of the most likeable
characters on the Simpson Oh totally I
feel like I can relate with Milhouse me
too everybody can like the like the guy
who's just nerdy and gets rejected all
the time and he's going oh he's callable
I'm very gullible yeah everybody's going
alright like any time a girl on the
internet hits me up I immediately
assumed this is real not a bot that you
know when she asked me to go to her
profile page on the separate website and
you know like oh they're not gonna
charge me any money
yeah but get my credit card information
anyway I'm like cool be safe girls hot
yeah might as well participate modern
romance modern romance yeah and it blows
up your spam inbox - totally I just
think it's kind of mean to do that I
like to go hey we should base this over
off of you and we're gonna be like
pretty accurate with your look and stuff
true it's never nice to be mean however
maybe you divided it you think so oh I'm
trying to see the bright side do you see
that black thing that picture frame yeah
can you grab that for a second so this
is me a universal at Shrek and even
though I paid money to look like that I
was still offended by how good it came
out
you think yeah like a beard this big I
gotta shave
Early's like muttonchops yeah the serial
killer ones oh I knew that guy who was
based off her Texas Chainsaw Massacre
I didn't realize he was like an
inspiration to you for like Norman Bates
and Buffalo Bill I mean because it's
like traumatic childhood like yeah
that's a lot of serial killers you know
oh my god that just broke my heart and
also maybe you wanna throw up a little
bit a little bit although I would be
bummed out if like Heaton like this
guy's like killing me and gonna turn me
into like you know like a couch I would
hate to be a couch what would you rather
be if there's any piece of furniture I
be it would be I want me to be a mug's
like freak out
oh yeah oh you know I want people to
drink out of me hope you'll sit on me I
don't feel like I'd have comfortable
enough skin like like you have really
soft skin you make a great couch thank
you I feel like you're gonna turn people
into something yeah could be a little
bit more inventive right you know like I
think it'd be cool if he like took
different body parts and like made the
perfect like woman for himself I think I
would be nice as a vest for a cat yeah
guy who they were like mob boss who
played with fat people or something like
that Sydney Greenstreet inspired for
Jabba the Hutt that would I don't know
if he was alive when that happened but
that would uh that'd be the ultimate
insult to me yeah we based Jabba the
Hutt off of you I mean I can relate to
Jabba the Hutt I've had my weight
struggles you know they fluctuate and
it's all about dieting and I always felt
like if Jabba the Hutt just wanted to
take better care of his health like
maybe watch your channel and like learn
how to eat sweets but you know hell for
your health job without wondering I've
been so miserable job would have been
Jabba the toothpick
since I'd have been like a Hut more like
uh or you know like it like a telephone
pole are you mean Hugh be skinny yeah Oh
fix he would be fit was great oh yeah
Aladdin and Tom Cruise yeah like I I
don't know why I never thought of that I
always saw myself in a lab if I came up
to stranger you haven't known Greg for
like ten years
stranger comes up to you I'm like monnet
I can show you the world then I should
have a carpet okay the time it's on a
magic rug it's just a regular IKEA
carpet
well yeah top-trending go subscribe to
their channel they're a fantastic
channel with awesome information if you
guys are new to this channel you can
subscribe today and become a reject my
net has a channel sweet eats yep you
should check out her channel if you want
to learn to be healthier but stay
delicious you should check out her
channel yeah we cover um healthy baking
and you know opt for healthier options
so yeah there's a co-host on there named
Jesse Jesse yes and Jesse asked monette
if I could give her my number and I said
Jesse now's not good timing in my life
but yes you could have my number and she
could totally hit me up be fun to hang
out with her and she she works out she
has a nice physique and she has a loving
personality at least from what I've seen
on YouTube so Jesse yeah maybe maybe
where it goes will see what her
boyfriend thinks yeah they're so cute
together
no they're not oh he's ugly he's not
they're both very they're a very
attractive couple this is not fair how
long they've been together two years
she's probably so bored of him both
personal trainers well she teaches
Pilates and they they're so he's also
Cersei yeah
what is a cute couple they're great
people you're a great person too yeah
yeah whatever
haha